hey killing over from a heart attack is
a dramatic way to die in the movies but
it's very different in reality this
misperception could prove deadly
especially for women heart disease is
the number one killer of women in the
u.s. yet many women can't recognize when
their disease takes a turn for the worse
the signs of an oncoming heart attack
are often different in women than men
chest pain that radiates down one arm
isn't as common in women and the
pressure or pain can pop up in bizarre
places like the jaw upper abdomen and
back other symptoms include shortness of
breath extreme fatigue dizziness
lightheadedness nausea fainting pressure
or pain in the neck and lower chest and
squeezing sensations around the abdomen
it's not clear why women experience
heart attacks differently part of the
reason could have to do with why women
are more prone to heart disease than men
for example diabetes increases the risk
of heart disease more in women so too
smoking lack of physical activity and
low levels of estrogen after menopause
despite their risks women are less
likely to get checked for heart disease
and each year more women die of the
disease than men so make sure you know
the signs and risks because heart
attacks are not just for Hollywood and
men